qué es la oscuridad para ustedes
quisiera que se tomarán unos segundos
incluso que cerraran los ojos y que ahí
en la intimidad de sus pensamientos se
contestarán esta pregunta que es la
oscuridad para mí
a lo mejor están pensando en palabras
como
[Música]
la angustia
nerviosismo e incertidumbre miedo
e incluso pánico terror o algunos otros
podrán estar pensando en curiosidad en
oportunidad o en descubrir algo nuevo
para mí la oscuridad se relaciona con
esos rincones de nuestra vida donde no
queremos escudriñar
con esas situaciones
[Música]
que básicamente no aceptamos o con esas
situaciones que se salen de nuestro
guión de vida
y mi percepción
es que en la actualidad vivimos
de una forma o en un sistema en el cual
nos hemos vuelto incluso adictos a
mostrar nuestro lado más brillante
que todos se enteren de todo lo bueno
que hacemos que nuestras vidas' parezcan
casi casi perfectas y bueno es una
tendencia natural del ser humano a todos
nos gusta ser reconocidos por lo bueno
que hacemos sin embargo yo creo que esta
tendencia se ha incrementado un poco más
con redes sociales si en facebook en
instagram en cualquier red social todo
mundo nos ve de hecho estamos como una
vitrina vivimos un aparador entonces
pues siempre queremos que vean nuestro
lado más luminoso
creo que esta tendencia nos ha llevado a
dejar de lado incluso a enemistarnos
[Música]
eso es lo que hablaba antes que es para
mí la oscuridad sus rincones donde no
queremos entrar y les doy un ejemplo
hace varias semanas ya meses estaba
leyendo un artículo en internet que me
pareció muy interesante porque decía un
mismo individuo en una persona sentada
frente a su computadora abre el facebook
y postea por ejemplo los deliciosos
tacos de barbacoa que se desayuno en la
mañana
o el viaje que hizo por europa o por
asia
o empieza a postear las fotos de su bebé
recién nacido y esa misma persona
en la otra ventana de su compu se mete
al google y le pone como quemó
rápidamente los calorías de los tacos de
barbacoa que acabo echar como pago la
deuda del viajecito europa
o como superó la depresión post-parto
que me está causando un recién nacido
entonces por un lado estamos
destacando lo más brillante de nosotros
pero en la intimidad del google donde
pensamos que nadie nos ve porque bueno
en tachar la anterior hay como
pavloviano dijo que siempre nos ven
en el internet de donde pensamos que
nadie nos ve en el google y preguntamos
eso que nos está inquietando eso que no
queremos compartir con los demás y yo lo
que creo que está provocando es
básicamente personas más ansiosas
personas y que están siendo estamos
siendo orillados a veces incluso
y actuar bajo una segunda naturaleza o
sea para estar siempre
utilizando la máscara de un personaje
nos convierte en personas que a veces
estamos bajo mucha mucha presión
qué causa esto
yo siento que vivimos en una sociedad
le llamo yo muy maniquea maniquea es
extremista y no solo la sociedad en
monterrey no solo lo hará la sociedad en
méxico sino ser humano a veces tendemos
a ser un poco extremistas con las
etiquetas y los juicios que utilizamos
hacia los demás y quiero darles dos
ejemplos para que nos quede claro a qué
me refiero con este extremismo
si yo les pregunto a ustedes que ve una
persona con discapacidad visual
quizá algunos de ustedes quizá la
mayoría piensen que una persona con
discapacidad visual ve oscuridad porque
no ve nada
y las estadísticas nos dicen que más o
menos es el 10 o el 15 por ciento de la
gente con discapacidad visual los que no
vemos nada
todos los demás tienen alguna percepción
visual poquitito poquito más o menos
mucha pero tienen percepción visual sin
embargo nuestra
percepción nos puede llevar a ponerlos a
todos en la canasta de gente ciega
es un ejemplo segundo ejemplo en 1950
hubo un mundial de fútbol en brasil
estaban jugando a la final brasil contra
uruguay
perdió brasil y así se le llamó el
maracanazo estaba en el estadio que era
el maracaná de brasil y el arquero de
brasil el portero barbosa durante todo
el mundial había sido considerado como
el mejor portero de la competencia en
ese último tiro que hace uruguay
pues los aficionados están frustrados
molestos dicen que se le fue no
entonces quedó marcado de por vida
decía él en una entrevista posterior
cuando su carrera se fue hacia abajo
debido a ese error que en brasil a un
criminal se le han máximo 30 años de
cárcel y decía a mí me sentenciaron de
por vida incluso hay una anécdota
en el mundial del 94 donde él intenta
entrar a la concentración de la
selección de brasil para hablar con los
jugadores darles ánimo motivarlos y el
cuerpo técnico no le permite la entrada
porque le dijeron que podía ser de mala
suerte
otra vez extremos no una acción buena no
se encumbra una acción mala nos derrumba
eso es el maniqueísmo y como estamos en
una vitrina donde todo el mundo nos ve
queremos siempre mostrar nuestro lado
más brillante
yo les quiero platicar mi recorrido a
través de mi oscuridad personal
yo soy ciego como ahorita lo mencionaron
desde los 6 años debido a una leucemia
de hecho todo en mí delata que soy ciego
ustedes me ven a la cara mis ojos mi
movimiento corporal y muchas de mis
acciones delatan que soy ciego no no
sería un secreto para nadie no sin
embargo esa no fue mi oscuridad mi
principal oscuridad y mi reto fue esto
que es mi bastón
desde el momento en que tome un bastón
hasta el momento en que use un bastón es
muy diferente agarrarlo a usarlo me
llevo unos 10 o 12 años más o menos
y todo empezó en la secundaria una
maestra una psicóloga voy a usar mi
bastón para que yo lograra más autonomía
yo no lo veía así para mí este bastón
era pena era un oso
yo decía no pero pues qué y cómo me voy
a ver si yo voy a seguir caminando por
toda la escuela con mi bastón este
chocando con los obstáculos no qué pena
no yo decía que osos y luego le meto el
bastón de las piernas a alguien y lo
tumbó
y lo peor escribe sí a usar el bastón va
a ser como decirle a todo el mundo que
si soy ciego lo paradójico es que todos
sabían no
todos sabían cómo que menos yo
y esa fue mi verdadera
oscuridades como esa habitación
prohibida de mi vida donde no quería
entrar pero también les platico como
entré a ella y cómo digerir esa
oscuridad para básicamente como ese
título de charla para brillar más mi
primer trabajo fue en diálogo en la
oscuridad que es una exhibición
donde hay áreas de la vida cotidiana un
parque una ciudad una cafetería pero en
completa oscuridad y hay gente como tú
que si ven agarran un bastón como este y
gente como yo que no vemos los guiamos
entonces es un intercambio de roles si
al final del recorrido había una
cafetería donde teníamos la oportunidad
de conversar con los visitantes ahí en
total oscuridad y resultó que ese
espacio de conversación se convirtió
en un área de desarrollo para mí eran
conversaciones que
en vez de victimizar mí me ayudaban
a ver todo lo que yo podía dar era un
área donde la gente hacía más preguntas
y no tantos juicios era un área donde la
gente me hacía ver mis potenciales esos
ejemplos
de repente la gente me decía oye pp
yo conozco unas personas ciegas por mi
casa y salen a la calle sólo se conocen
toda la ciudad
tú también sales sólo decía no
y después otro grupo no se oye pp yo
conozco las personas ciegas buenísimas
para la música tiene un oído
privilegiado tú también y no
y lo otro comicio no yo no tengo una
vecina que no ve y cocina todos los días
cocina leche loncha el expósito to time
cocinas
pero bueno tanto no me igual sí y empecé
a explorar a través de esas preguntas
empecé a desarrollarme y empecé a entrar
a esa oscuridad a la cual yo no quería
entrar
que comience a entrar y encontré o
concluir que entrar a esa
a ese rincón en el cual yo no quería
escudriñar
me estaba limitando supe que al entrar a
esa oscuridad
yo me volvía más libre
hoy puedo estar por algunas de las
calles de esta ciudad con bastante
independencia cocino lo del oído de la
música eso no todavía está pendiente no
[Música]
y bueno
esto de lo que estoy hablando la
psicología positiva le llama el permiso
de ser humano el permiso darnos permiso
darnos chance de ser quien somos o el
mindfulness lo llama darle la mano a
nuestras emociones desagradables
yo extraje tres conclusiones de esto que
me ocurrió la primera conclusión es que
todo es relativo a pesar de que estemos
siendo observados por toda la gente
hasta alrededor no hay extremos todo es
relativo yo me cuenta cuando yo
observaba a los visitantes que entraban
a diálogo nos cuida con su bastón y
decía mira hace cinco minutos
todos ellos veían ahorita les apagamos
la luz y ya no ven son ciegos y unos
ciegos muy malos por cierto porque
caminan muy despacito chocaban con todo
este les da una manzana en la mano y me
decían que era una cebolla este el
sándwich que se compraron para comerse
lo estaban comiendo por la nariz
entonces
yo decía pues este son muy malos ciegos
no y si ahí lo paradójico es que todos
vivimos al borde de un cambio tan
abrupto como puede ser una discapacidad
la discapacidad más o menos el 80 85 por
ciento de las discapacidades son
adquiridas
o sea un accidente o una enfermedad nos
pueden llevar ese espacio y todos
estamos en constante riesgo de ello todo
es todo relativo segundo
nuestro guión de vida lo podemos
reinterpretar creo que no está en el
guión de vida usted es perder la vista
tampoco estaba en mi rol el millón de
vida
sin embargo lo podemos reinterpretar
recuerdo que había gente que me decía
oye pues pobrecito de ti porque cuando
tengas una esposa o una novia no la vas
a conocer
no vas a ver su cara cuando tengas un
hijo pues nunca lo vas a ver y bueno hoy
tengo una esposa que está sentada y
tengo también un hijo que no vino este y
a los dos aprendí he aprendido a
conocerlos a disfrutar los de otras
formas o también cuando la gente me
decía que lástima que no ves las
montañas en monterrey los paisajes que
tenemos y a mí me encanta ir a las
montañas me gusta mucho disfruto de los
paisajes de otra forma y la vista el
sentido de la vista no tiene el
monopolio de la vida
la vida tiene muchas otras formas de
entenderse y disfrutarse entonces
podemos reinterpretar nuestro guión de
vida tercero
lo que yo le llamaría buscarnos unos
googles humanos o sea buscar espacios
personas conversaciones donde podamos
platicar eso que le platicamos al google
preguntar eso le preguntamos al google
sin el temor de ser juzgados ese espacio
como el que yo tuve en esa cafetería me
ayudó muchísimo para
percibir me otra forma entonces tener
esos permisos de entrar a nuestras
oscuridades
en un cuento muy breve que ilustra lo
que hoy les viene a compartir se llama
la llave y está contenido en las
aventuras del mula nasrudín lo cuento
muy rápido
dice cuento que un día estaba el mulá en
la calle agachado liado buscando algo en
el piso
pasa un hombre y le dice mula que estás
buscando disimular mi llave
el hombre se acuclilla junto al mula y
empiezan a buscar los dos y después de
un minuto le dice el hombre hoy en mula
donde se cayó la llave y disimula allá
adentro en mi casa
ilícitos porque estoy buscando a que
fuera y sé por qué aquí afuera hay más
luz
la conclusión por mi parte es que
siempre estamos al filo del cambio lo
vimos en los sismos ahora en septiembre
en la ciudad de méxico y en otras
ciudades del país lo vemos con la
inseguridad lo vemos con las
enfermedades siempre estamos al filo de
un cambio abrupto entonces mi invitación
es a que sea en el permiso de entrar a
esa habitación oscura busquen la llave
ahí porque creo que esa llave así como a
mí nos puede ayudar a vivir con toda
libertad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]